ragazzi e benvenuti in questo nuovo
video oggi parleremo di capelli
infatti mi avete chiesto in tantissimi
dei consigli su uno delle pettinature
delle acconciature per le vostre feste
quindi ho pensato di proporvi quattro
opzioni che secondo me sono carine sono
facili da realizzare ma soprattutto sono
d'effetto partiamo subito dalla prima
che secondo me è la più semplice da fare
che fosse impicci stima non ci crederete
neanche da quanto semplice tutto quello
che vi serve per questa pettinatura è un
elastico e voi direte cosa è una cosa
esatto è una coda ma attenzione con un
piccolo trucchetto diventano coda un po
più particolare un po più legate un po
più carina vediamo subito come
realizzarla allora tutto quello che
dovete fare quindi è una semplice coda
bassa vi volete aiutare con la spazzola
per tirare bene i capelli e fate la
vostra codino e voi direte tutto qui
aspetto adesso faccio vedere questo
adesso mi giro per farvi vedere
esattamente cosa dovete fare tutto
quello che dovete fare è semplicemente
allentare un pochino il vostro elastico
di modo che si crei uno spazio tra la
testa appunto è elastico
dopo di ciò create un buchino proprio
qui in mezzo vedete così e non dovete
far altro che girare la vostra codina
all'interno di questo buco per poi
stringerla bene questa è la codeina
caviglione fuori vedete che secondo me è
molto molto elegante molto carina e
molto sobria quelle meno sobri e le
facciamo violanti è perfetta secondo me
per io la farei per la cena di natale
con parenti sarà un po più impostata un
po più formale passiamo alla seconda
acconciatura si tratta di uno chignon ci
servirà questo casino che non mi ricordo
mai come si chiami però
quello per fare lo chignon e nella laica
delle forcine e un elastico
anche qui poca roba allora questo
chignon lo posizionerei a un'altezza
media perché quello poi più alto lo
facciamo dopo quindi prendiamo se volete
io tipo di lancio perché mi piacciono
lasciamo 2 giu fettine avanti così e
andiamo a collezionare ben i capelli per
fare non ho il nostro raccolto come al
tetto direi qui
dopo di ciò prendiamo il nostro così no
e ci facciamo passare dentro la coda
vedete poi sappiamo bene i capelli ma
anche il coprono tutto to broccolino e
poi giriamo intorno poi fissarli bene
con degli invisibili o delle forcine
allora qui adesso non me li cioè si
possono tenere sia così va bè lisci
adesso non mi sono passate la piazza
quindi le punte sono un po così
oppure volendo si possono anche girare
stile boccolo la punta un po più
insomma mossa il raccolto è anche questo
molto elegante molto classico è
adattissimo secondo me a qualsiasi cena
di natale ma anche perché no il
capodanno se andavi insomma un capodanno
un po più come posso dire sobrio
classico
[Musica]
quindi non al mio per la terza
acconciatura potete lasciar perdere il
cosino e prendere il cotone cosa ne
pensate
questo sì che è un signor chignon allora
sarà uno chignon molto alto
possiamo siano share i giusti come come
abbiamo fatto prima ci aspetti giu
oppure in questo caso vi farò vedere
insomma i capelli tutti tirati indietro
quindi molto molto bon ton sono pechino
che comunque tutto è molto bolton
quindi la coda sarà come abbiamo detto
bella alta più alta la fase meglio
allora ecco la nostra comune prendiamo
il nostro cordone e come abbiamo fatto
prima insomma facciamo lo stesso
procedimento
ed è subito sì sì la principessa parlo
ora andiamo come prima
fissare bene il nostro figlio mi sento
molto evita di rivombrosa
ok il problema quando uno realtà e
filtro signor però chiaramente vedete
che bisogna sistemare questa zona quindi
direi un vertecchi pettinino un bel po
di lancio ed è pure io adesso non
abbondano chiaramente perché sono poi
dopo non riesco a fare presso tirate
bene bene bene così poi se mi danno al
sito come nel mio caso queste diciamo i
capelli un po più radi vicino alla
calzatura possiamo andare con un
ombretto del colore i nostri capelli
oppure nel mio caso io uso la palette
del contouring andiamo leggermente a
riempire questi buchini vedete senza
chiaramente esagerare giusto per non
fare proprio vedere la netta differenza
come vedete con questi bettini e la
lacca andiamo a fissare bene
e il gioco è fatto questo è il nostro
magazine
che a questo punto direi forse per la
cena in famiglia un po too much quindi
magari per il capodanno
ed eccoci arrivati alla quarta ed ultima
non acconciatura perché le acconciature
più una piega è una piega mossa che io
realizzo spesso quindi oggi ve la
propongo e diciamo che all'inizio non è
facilissima da fare cioè ci devi
prendere un po la mano
tra l'altro io non so se con tutte le
piastre si possa realizzare io la ghd
che ha fatto apposta sia per lisciare
che per insomma fare questo mosso
partiamo subito chiaramente ho fatto
scaldare una piastra serve la piastra
una pinza e legge software prima di
passare la piastra di consiglio come ho
fatto io di mettere una protezione
termica appunto per la piastra una sorta
di primer per i capelli e partiamo
subito allora cercherò di spiegarvi come
fare allora dovete prendere la piastra e
girarla la sua canali se non vi verrà
molto facile girarla in questo modo
[Musica]
sì lo so sembra facile però mi ricordo
all'inizio quando la vedevo fare dal mio
parrucchiere dicevo cavolo non è una
cavolata poi la facevo io e non mi
veniva quindi come vi ho detto prima
dovete esercitarvi un attimo però una
volta che prendi insomma la mano è molto
molto semplice quindi d'andata giro
e proseguo tengono artimino lì perché si
formi il mosso
ed ecco qua se siete ricci come me vi
consiglio soprattutto vicino
all'attaccatura di insistere un poker di
piastra re diciamo l'attaccatura per poi
proseguire insomma col boccolo però
almeno non rischiate che ci sia il mosso
sotto e il riccio all'attaccatura è
tremendo siamo quasi arrivati alla fine
[Musica]
o cari
è mosso sia chiaramente io vi consiglio
di andare a testa in giù così abbondare
con la latta tornare adesso in su
e
buon natale il gioco è fatto il mosso
c'è il volume pure questa potete usare
diciamo sempre cioè e meno particolare
rispetto agli altri senza una piega e
potete farvi tutti i giorni un bel mosso
la via di mezzo e siete pronti per le
vostre feste
fatemi sapere qua sotto con un commento
quale di queste pettinature vi è
piaciuta di più quale magari volete
provare a realizzare magari per una cena
di natale avevo perso capodanno e niente
come al solito sarebbe piaciuto il video
cliccate mi piace e iscrivetevi al
canale se non l'avete ancora fatto
eseguite su tutti gli altri social
instagram facebook e musicali
[Musica]